have you had a lot of time to travel
around Japan now uh not that much you've
been traveling a bit in your yeah we
went on a trip with bej our first trip
went too and
atami it was really good really enjoyed
it nice to finally be able to travel
with the baby as well oh yeah even
though it was hard everything takes like
three hours longer than he should but no
it's good it's really fun uh those
places were good we went up the volcano
thing yeah yeah beautiful
is it the one with the black eggs like
the onset oh no
that's SC close yeah I don't scam it is
close yeah same prefix I that area is
all really nice yeah we haven't gone far
though I think furthest wi was ala so
yeah you haven't gone to kushu yet no oh
kushu and are my two favor we were
planning to go but we were like that's
too far with a baby so yeah I mean for
kushu it's it's kind of tough cuz it's
like and Hokkaido too it's like five
hours train or 2hour flight but then
flights suck so you're like h i don't
are they Japanese flights not good I
mean no flights are good I mean it's
better than normal but it's still still
miserable okay it's like a flight sucks
and if you go with Shin Ken you can only
go to like the very like beginning of Q
rest of it is all C no no no you can the
sh goes all the way to um um uh
kakushima does it yeah I thought it
stops in uh [__] you have to tr you
have to change and then there's another
bullet train that goes all the way down
to Kima I did not know that and there's
one that goes to Nagasaki they have
their own completely own bullet train
it's completely different design it's
really cool they've got like a wood
version I did not know that it's really
cool um sh line yeah goes
to wow I did not know that show can you
can you show the uh the wooden shink you
no no no it's it's been on for a while
really oh [__] cuz my understanding of
shinen is you could only go as far as
okay
um just like
[Music]
has interior wooden bullet trains yeah
there's like one that has like a really
beautiful oh [__]
sake oh it's a I didn't know that was a
shin no no no it's one of them maybe it
is maybe I got it wrong there is one
that's really nice cush also has the
seven seven C's which is this extremely
luxury classical they know how to make
it fancy they make a lot of things fancy
I to say with how fast the Shen sense is
going do you want it to be built out of
woods it's just no no sorry like the
inside they have a little
wood okay when I when I saw wood I was
like what the friction of the air bur in
Flames
like it's like Shen gunon ghost wooden
sh bad idea just splits is flying
everywhere plastic she well I guess oh
they got their own little weird one look
at that it's got like a interior Japan's
train culture is just on another level
yeah I can see why train exist man the
middle one yeah yeah I didn't know that
was a thing
one no no before it they're insane yeah
there's no talk everything in Japan but
definitely one for trains oh that's a
render
Jesus well that's not what I look like
have you guys ritten the not the
business but the first class in Shan
Canen yeah the grand class Grand class
it's so good I've still never di can
never go back grand class it's so good
it's so good cuz it's like a it's like
an extra 30 bucks on top of the green so
I guess normal it' be like an extra 50
is this only for certain chents only for
ones that go
north so yeah so Jr East and West are
separated and it's only uh Jr East that
that has the new cars the Jr cuz even
the green cars so there's three classes
in ch normal green and Grand but uh the
one that goes to Osaka only has green
and normal I see and the green one is a
lot older and it's not as nice and then
even if the you go uh East or North uh
the green is really nice as well a lot
more spacious lot nicer but the grand
class is amazing and I like an extra 30
bucks it's quiet and you get you get
unlimited beverages any beverage you
want you get food you get snacks as and
you get your own personal service it's
more sound isolated yes yes way quieter
and fully reclining chair I might dud so
don't sleep on it the problem is that
most tourists don't do it because you
can't you can't get the um you can't use
the rail pass on it right and it chin is
already quite expensive um so you add on
an extra so C like the longer you go the
more it costs but then you get more
value out of it so it's worth it it's
it's definitely worth it I took it I
took it yesterday from uh oh fancy which
is a 3our I get fancy sometimes
three-hour bll train I think think it
was a lot of time I think it was Neiman
yeah for the ticket and I think the
regular is uh so two so 20,000 yen nor
is 12,000 okay so it's I guess it's like
8,000 Yen more which is what 50 bucks
yeah but I think the amount of coffee
and tea I drank
was they haveo machine that's the
important thing oh they make it all
fresh I don't think it's a freshing
machine like pour over but it's all
really good and they give you these
chocolates the little sea salt
chocolates I get chocolates well it's
cuz they don't like you
okay kid it's it's the you didn't blink
when you let them in yeah yeah you
didn't do full blinks I didn't get a
snack you do get snacks you do yeah you
get like a little it's really really
nice what's your like bucket list right
now of like places you want to visit
next to you kind do for sure yeah yeah I
was I was kind of piss I missed out last
year cuz all of a sudden everyone was in
hokaido I think you were in hokaido
Chris was in hokaido Mar was like I'm
going to hokaido with my friend I'm like
cool I'll just stay
here it's it's just fun because there
snow festival or something like that
yeah I actually didn't like the snow
Festival much I heard that good last
year it was it was it was okay like the
stuff's really impressive but you kind
of see one you're like this is really
cool it's really impressive and then you
have to like waddle through so many
people that's never fun and you're like
okay I got to see another one again more
busy because it's been a while since it
was open because of Co H yeah absolutely
it was delayed for like two years
exactly and I mean it's definitely like
amazing to look at but I wouldn't plan a
trip to go see it because I just think
that you it's so hard to do anything on
that period it's there all the
restaurants are full uh all the hotels
are really expensive it's it's okay but
I feel like sapora is just better for
The Vibes in general like go go for the
city not for the snow Fest
it's such a cool City I mean that area
is just so cool in general and so much
to do uh I always thought the snow
Festival would just be like a nice
little extro if I got to experience even
like the country side of H is dope as
[__] it's some of the most beautiful
scenery I've ever seen in Japan my
favorite ice cream place in the world is
in hoko my favorite soup curry place in
the world many
fav the goat and they're right next to
each
other they 30 minute drive it's yeah
it's like 20 30 minut drive but it's
worth it because you eat the amazing
soup curry you're so full you're like
God I'm so full I wish I had ice cream
let's drive 30 minutes to get ice cream
it's so good ice cream totally it's this
it's this Farm uh and in they open
winter and and spring but both times it
looks really beautiful because and it's
uh right um it's got a beautiful view of
Mount yote um and so you can have this
amazingly homemade gelato uh and then
have like a coffee with the with the
milk from the farm everything milk you
get like processed ask for the
photo we've on the podcast in the Pasto
has just likeed food G food okay I'm
actually not a fan of their milk uh we
you crch
gone it's it's just way too [__]
heavy I I don't I don't drink the milk
straight I have it in things like the
butter it's amazing okay it's amazing
but like I remember like every staying
in like every hotel in Hokkaido uh they
have like they give you like the H and
then for breakfast and I take like two
sips and I'm like I'm not even hungry
anymore this is this is just like
drinking cream it's one step away from
your it's like it's like 400 calories of
[__] yeah that's all I need
baby definitely recommend H okay yeah
there some beautiful really really
beautifulu is like fun Vibes where
everyone's really happy and really chill
and every wants to chat Hokkaido is more
like you go for like an amazing kind of
kind of chill vacation what are youling
about you
[__] [__] high school again shake
hands a little bit shaking
toes my God Sor you were saying I'm [__]
it's fine I'll go my own I'll try I'll
[__] myself I'll play foot myself it's
fine I can I can I can reach I can I can
reach down where are you where are you I
don't know where you is that is that you
or is that Felix I don't know who's this
in my touching is this Joey Joey fcking
godam it I'm fing with Joey again I take
all the love you didn't smile at all